we have a lot to talk about do we not I
think so I think I mean rehearsal was a
while ago
yeah really what we rehearsed this show
six years ago know what to talk about
you know it's what the hell was that
whose phone was that who's that guy
this guy right here okay do you know who
it was who was calling you you think it
was your mom power back I think you
should call her back absolutely and just
say mom I'm in a taping of Conan and
then explain who Conan is what's up yeah
yeah that's great okay you're the most
chill person oh it was Brandon it was
not your mom I don't wanna [ __ ] the
Brandon hello is this Brandon Brandon is
this Brandon put her on speaker what's
this guy's name yeah
and what is your name why aren't you
running this conversation why am i
running this conversation and why are
you still man splint spreading like no
one I've ever seen
you're the most cocky son of a [ __ ]
I've ever seen you're sitting here like
this you just call this is Conan O'Brien
you called during the taping of the show
and we're trying to sort of get the show
going so I'm gonna put you back on with
your friend okay
tell him to please close tell him to
please close his legs and wear underwear
next time we're good all right hey
thanks nice to meet you well there's no
time for our guests tonight I will have
Brandon on tomorrow I like to handle
those problems myself yeah yeah that's
what I do